that's no that sucks yeah I hope our fan
wouldn't try to extort this extort this
I said like toras and extort
us extort
this that's the fattest Mexican [__]
ever talk about
[Applause]
[Music]
extortion
perf
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect hey what's up everybody
I'm Thomas dope as Yola whatever you
want to call me I'm here with my co-host
Marty O'Neal what's up folks what's up
guys it's another solo episode welcome
back it's just Marty and I the teachers
out of the room let's say whatever we
want to say and I'm going to say this
January started off amazing everyone's
telling the truth everyone's calling
people out I love this I don't like to
confront people cuz I don't want to hurt
Hur their feelings mhm when I see other
people do I'm like yeah you don't care
about their feelings and I love seeing
it that's great I'm going to go back to
what I was doing but just just watching
this Cat Williams thing made me so
happy because that's exactly the way I
would be talking if all of my stuff was
true like what you say huh that's
exactly the kind of vibe I would have so
if you haven't seen it Shannon sharp
Shannon sharp yes the tight end Shannon
sharp has his own talk show we've talked
about it before he's doing great he's
had some really big guests on recently
at catam Shan Sharp's technically the
homie too by the Way's over here
shooting getting advice from him it's
cool
um you're never going to rebuttal
Shannon sharp you notice a few times
Shannon sharp said some stuff and cow
was like yeah I just as I explained to
you right now there's a few times he was
like don't say nothing he sh a sharp
he'll eat me yeah he has the respect of
like a legend but when you're when
you're actually around him and you just
like understand how big his back is and
[__] like it's just different when
you're Cat Williams
especially just like a he can just hop
on his shoulder he probably just felt
very comfortable just getting it all off
his chest right there yeah and he knows
he's so funny shanon sh's not going to
say nothing crazy yeah right so if you
haven't watched it I think it is the
biggest podcast episode since Elon mus
episode that's fair it is three days
it's almost 40 million views already and
that's on a newer show I think that
shows a lot that shows a lot of people
just want to hear what's going on if you
have time go watch it I thought it was
great he really broke it down and uh I
see this is the thing with me I don't
like saying things because it's like I
don't really like that person because in
two years I'm have to meet that person
and go yeah I just don't like you and
I'm nice I don't want to hurt no one's
feelings I don't like Steve Harvey you
know that I've said it I've never said
it on camera but I don't like him just
don't like him every time I watch Family
Feud he's kind of he's kind of
Prejudiced and that's kind of crazy to
say dude dude he he's kind of he's kind
of one-sided anytime there's a white
family on that show he's like you won a
can I watch Family Feud I used to watch
that [__] I'm like what Steve Harvey's
on here the whole ship went down I keep
thinking of Kings of Comedy as the ship
went down the funniest thing he said in
that whole thing and I'm like wow Steve
Harvey wait how you being so B oh you're
a racist I didn't know you were gu like
that I'm just saying it cuz I'm being
dumb I don't know if he is I just
noticed that a multiple times I watched
Family Feud go why why you acting like
that I don't like you anymore and I
continued my life it's not like he
affects my life but hearing Cat Williams
go hard on him was like so it's not just
me something's wrong he's off he seems
very not genuine he brutalized him on
stage too I think I think it was way
before that happened I don't know if you
saw that clip yeah he went in on them
too in front of a live studio not even
it was like a theater or something
oh I just if you're the funniest person
you can say what you want cuz if you're
going to rebuttal I'm going to burn you
again shut up just listen that's what he
did the entire episode to the world mhm
not one person has come out and go he's
a liar yeah but that's how he feels I
don't remember it that way like you know
who says that Liars
also we've talked about it I've talked
to you about it I used to love ludicrous
he used to be cool mhm and then I found
out that video of him
like slapping that dude in the bathroom
in that music video or hitting him or
whatever it was supposed to be M Dre
he's supposed to be making fun of M Dre
because M Dre approached him to sign him
one time so he just makes fun of the guy
in the music video since that day I'm
done I don't I like L know that's why I
don't like ludicrous like you don't say
that [__] what are you what are you
doing what are you doing he out rap you
right now he's dead he's still harder
than you I think ludicrous is cool as
like a dude and a per that [__] pissed
me off a lot do people know about that
or no I saw it through dark M you know
that's about M Dre right like what is
that why he's wearing Oakland is that
why he's wearing the a gear I don't like
this guy no more no mat slander will be
no that's crazy MH no not unless he
fought you and beat you up and they like
I don't like him like all right
justifiably beat your ass different
anyway when Cat Williams started going
on ludicrous was funny and I'm like that
sucks and once again the truth is coming
out January this is week one and we are
popping with good [__] all right ludic
I'm going to say this right now if you
look at me and say hey I went to a party
I saw that guy Thomas going so I'm going
to that one weird room IID come out and
go no you didn't I don't want to be at
parties I snapchated my whole night I
went home what I wouldn't write you a
rap did you see his
response ludicrous wrote a rap oh he did
he wrote a rap Mar
he when's the last time lus wrath
1999 pous one credits I forgot he was a
rapper he wrote
a damn right like he's an actor now I
get it ludicrous is the actor I get it I
think of him with the the Big Head the
cartoon that's why I loved him dude
that's why I loved him dude but look it
sorry ludicrous if you ever like yo
we're going to come on the show I'm
sorry you can bring it up to me if you
want but I stand on it it really upset
me that that's supposed to be M Dre just
making fun of him like that that's crazy
also I don't I don't know how he just
wrote a
rap Marty call me something back in the
day when he started busting
up it's the guiltiest thing I've ever
seen in my life he's literally singing
being the age of like responding back
and forth through video like this is
really like imature very
immature I would never rap battle you I
like Cat Williams energy of being like
okay I'm older now I'm a legend I'm one
of the best people to ever do this [__]
I need to get all this off my chest
because a lot of the people that I see
that are like my peers around here have
been doing all this [__] that like I've
been I don't like yeah and I I didn't
I've only watched a couple of the clips
I still got to sit down and watch the
whole thing whole thing like this uhhuh
all I was like yeah I love hearing you
love Brandy M that's all I wanted to
hear Cat Williams every single thing you
say I agree
yes Bernie Ma's the
man that's all I needed to hear he's
like I don't know about Steve Harvey me
neither I love Bernie ma me too C
Williams let's chess bump if you fa me
I'm a Money Mike chess bump like I was
saying earlier though I went back and
watched Pimp Chronicles one I put that
up against anything I love the little uh
dialogue at the beginning with Snoop 2
where he's like pumping him up he's like
snoop's giving him a little motivation
there are eight blunts simultaneously
going
around
I you you forget about Cat Williams
because he doesn't put out a lot of
stuff lately
MH but it's kind of like one of those oh
yeah open it up like you remember all
these specials like because you always
jelle he's so relev he's always there
he's always relev he's always there he's
on Rogan he's always there he's on Rog
he's always there he's in the news he's
getting in chample he's doing this you
don't hear about C Williams as much
anymore last time I heard C Williams
when he fought that child remember that
yeah yeah he's the size of that child
he's a little guy I understand all right
mhm but just watching it if you have you
have time go watch it it was great I
loved it what a way to start the year
also this is a good this is a good way
to start I said it on the 30th I'm like
you know what I got to stop being such a
little dick such a little bastard and go
no I don't like the way they do things I
don't want to work with them I don't
want to hang out with them I don't want
I got to stop being that
guy because it's like well no he litters
bro do you think I want to chill with
somebody that litters like bro Maybe it
just he was like oh I shouldn't litter
I'll stop littering you're right then a
great great guy now I got to stop being
Jerry Seinfeld and finding one thing
going nah I'm good I don't want to hang
out I don't want to be around I'm gonna
go home bro there's only so many days I
just go
home so saying this I saw fluffy and uh
George Lopez give a speech of the Golden
Globes together oh no [__] funny it
started off real funny cuz you know
fluffy and George Lopez the guy didn't
bring up George Lopez or George Lopez
didn't help out fluffy and fluffy kind
of had a there's a thing I saw about
he's like well you know could have
helped me but he didn't now I'm bigger
it's fine well K yeah Ken Flores was
saying Ken Flores was was talking
somewhat about it yeah and
uh yeah they did a little thing together
it was cool I like seeing things
together when it's not like forced like
they probably went bro you're funny I'm
funny like why are we doing this mhm
same thing with Burner like the same
thing I'm like as he's sitting here I'm
like why are we doing doing this like
why why why are we not you know what we
could do if we both like yeah you're
cool you're cool done mhm that's all it
needs to be because off camera I've told
you I've talked to this man like three
times since the episode
M fine cool every time Goofy and funny
every single time like every time I
could tell like oh this was high I could
last time like I could hear it in his
voice like Jesus this is coming out a
little out of order so we're just kind
of the b in real time the burner episode
just dropped yesterday dropped yesterday
in real time and then Jake Johnson's
dropping next week this is two weeks
from now sorry guys we just want to make
sure we're ahead of the game we're not
12:30 it's still on uploaded like nah
we're just trying to do do better two
days in a row I've gotten up gone the
tread drink my drinks drink all my stuff
I feel a lot
better trying to start like this this
thing in my brain but as far as work
I've been [__] on a psychotic Terror
yeah but also you you your wife's been
out of state you have three kids it's
always different dude it's never going
to be the same you're always going to I
have three
kids it's a lot of work yeah it is you
you you have 12 hours a day everybody
wants a kid so you got three of them and
they you know what I mean and then you
get your wife uh Bill's tickets to go to
Miami for [__] Christmas and then now
you're left to your own devices not like
I you're left your own devices Marty
called me on Saturday morning I have
four soccer games he text me a picture
of his son at a party eating cake he
goes two soccer games down birthday
party in the middle two soccer games to
go this full midday is like yeah I'll
eat some cake before I crush this next
team and in the midst of all that I was
editing this three and a half hour
goddamn burner episode you're smart you
ever seen a white man just on a
field just typing in it's it's Marty
just look for the
Hat yeah but we ped through we had some
technical difficulties across the board
this episode it was a big file we got it
up uh feel really great about it it had
to happen just was such a big win for
the community if felt so nice seeing
everybody's it's like felt too everybody
just felt so happy that it happened that
felt great M even my brother was like
bro what re Rosie s is like wait
what he's on the show I go I know cuz
all my close F like how you do I got be
honest bro I don't think he likes me and
that was years ago like but I'm doing my
own thing it's okay and then it got
years later then you know you guys saw
the episode so it was great he was like
so casually funny too Northern
California he's just a regular Mexican
dude that gets high as hell used to trap
it out and take
drugs yeah
right yo and he's like my favorite B the
doors and went I hate everyone that told
me you suck I hate everyone that told me
you're not awesome and fun I hate anyone
that said anything different because
this guy's very cool and before when he
got here he was like I got time today
ask me whatever you want that was his
whole energy when he sat down book I'm I
got nowhere to be I'm here to chill and
do this like I love that [__] it was
awesome so for everyone out there go
watch the burner episode that happened
two weeks ago from this episode and last
week's episode Jake Johnson
self-reliance now streaming on Hulu what
a movie I loved the movie I'm not saying
because he was on the show I'm a movie
person I thought the movie was great
there was a few times where it made me
think no is this where it's going to go
and it didn't so I'm so excited it was a
great great movie super fun so go watch
it we're going actually tonight's the
this is real time so tonight we're going
to our first movie I've never been to a
movie premier Hulu Premiere we're going
to a real movie premiere tonight so Jake
Johnson text me the next day he's like
yo you and Marty you should come by you
know you have any of those joints that's
okay
too so um I'm gonna come stacked tonight
remember when we get the same guest as
Jimmy Fallon on the podcast Marty text
me that last night guys Jimmy Fallon had
Jake Johnson last night and our episode
comes out in a few days he's like man we
got the same guest like I gu guess we do
get the same guest M I guess but that's
almost like yo I've eaten all that no a
different restaurant but I've eaten that
and and Shout out while we're doing the
recap shout out to Ken Flores for coming
through with one of the funniest
episodes of all time hilarious two and a
half million views on Facebook on two
clips inside the first week is insane
for a comedian that not the whole world
doesn't know about and you said he's not
even verified yet come
on she was insane so shout out on
Facebook shout out to everybody on Tik
Tok and Instagram and Twitter and
everybody on the Community page and
YouTube thank you for supporting these
and on
Spotify oh yeah yeah yeah it's on that
behind your computer me a rent and Sh
you're
good oh I went to Camp Flor as a show
hilarious nice it was funny the whole
the whole room was ready bro everybody
was so excited the it was great did it
come out before the episode like yes yes
I saw a few fans there cool M yeah
um so yeah shout out to Ken Flores it
was really fun sorry we're just catching
up real quick guys just doing a little
yeah a little catch up because we
haven't been here in a while together
it's the first solo of the
year yeah last week was the one year
since Ted Talk that seemed like 12 years
ago well and simultaneously it still
seems like we just got past it for me it
doesn't we went to another Studio
mhm I've been in [__] seven States
since then yeah so much has happened
since then A lot's happened man a lot we
moved to a house mhm know like a lot's
happened since the Ted Talk it's kind of
crazy to think about it I built the full
backyard your house is done did the
marathon yeah doesn't seem now it's like
whoa that that was a long time ago all
these legendary episodes that have
happened too cool super sick um so with
that being said guys
I think that's we're good on the catchup
for now damn you ripped that mother I
can see the veins and the joint you see
it yeah that's what you know that's what
you know um okay here we go so this year
this is the year I [__] start finally
start open mics I'm gonna do it this
year I'm really excited whether I go up
and talk for 10 minutes or I go up and
crush it for 10 minutes either way it's
fine um I'm going start doing that I've
I've I've had eight years of jokes I've
been writing of just stupid and not even
jokes just stupid premises of things you
know I'm always leaning toward the I Am
cam floor is I have horrible things to
say and then Fluffy's like yo you got to
keep it clean if you want to go far I go
and I'm always I'm I'm like that too I
think I'm just do whatever I want so on
this show I hold back certain things I I
just can't say it I don't want to I
don't want to risk the channel for me to
go I don't want that so I'm not going to
risk the channel today but today I'm
going to talk a little just I have a few
ideas things I you guys remember every
single thing I've ever wrote down is
just stuff that I go Rosie I need to
write that down real quick that was
funny so
um yeah and this just stupid
observations it's like Seinfeld rated R
I feel but there was also there's a
bunch of [__] Marty can you go to the
Mexicans guys I wrote these things down
and uh I have a few things I want to say
let's go over if you think I if you
agree write in the comments
I thought of it the other day cuz my
friend goes no I got some Mexican guy to
do it and I'm
like is that good is that
good or is this is this bad and then I
realized I hired a Mexican guy to do it
can mean two different things you walk
in see Marty's backyard and go wow
Immaculate Caesar's Palace waterfall
yeah I got some Mexicans to do it like
damn they crush it
or you can go anywhere in skid row and
go who built this building and the owner
going to go I got some Mexicans to do
it it's just how you say it I got some
Mexicans to do it I got some Mexicans to
do it right it's either the best thing
he ever did or the worst thing he ever
did America all right that's you you let
us
in you did he let us in and now we're
either going to build a wall behind us
or not do [__] most of them are just
having kids I'm talking about from
experience most Mexican fools my age in
the ghetto areas where I'm from [__]
they have had one job for one summer
Section 8 is popping welfare is flying
let's have another one y always got 250
extra I have four I Rose Rosie's my my
mother-in-law used to work Rosie's mom
used to work for the Social Security
office and her job was to make sure that
you deserve
welfare she was the investigator she had
to go to people's house and go you have
a
Bentley why are you on welfare it's a
big thing in my town Merced is one of
the quickest places you can get Section
8 in the
country so growing up there was crazy
I've grown up with so many people I'm
just paying for my food struggling in
college and watching this lady fully
Gucci out like just pay with EBT I'm
like I can't even get that cuz I make
too I go to school and I get financial
aid I can't get food
stamps all right sick I have family
members you jerks that have food stamps
but have houses stop being
ghetto struggle a little bit you know
what I'm talking about I have family
members I have EBT right now you own
cars and have a house and wear
Jay's your phone's newer than mine sorry
I'm over here talking [__] about my
family stop doing that it's free money
man you got to get it the government I'm
going to let the government assist me I
assist you [__] everyone that's ever
paid taxes assist you think the
government's like yo we made 6 trillion
let's bust off a billion for the home it
doesn't work that way we are paying for
this every time you're like I'm let the
government pay no it's your neighbor
it's your neighbor paying for it so damn
how we get into that yeah it's either
Mexican good or Mexican
bad that's hilarious it's it's the
truest [__] my Grandma will say that
[__] my grandma's a Mexican by all
Mexican guys
like where are we going with they good
or bad like it's always bad it's always
bad I went to my grandma's and my dad
was in the office with a hole in the
wall
going I'm like Dad what are you doing I
you know I don't go to my grandma too
often I live here so I'm like damn I
haven't seen my dad work doing stuff in
a while I'm sitting behind him like I'm
a kid like so what are you doing it two
weeks ago during christas M it's like we
heard some Mexican guy and he didn't
wire anything right and I'm like you're
Mexican W you say you hired a [__] ass
worker even Mexicans go [__] Mexicans
dude and then when they do shake like
[__] Mexicans I swear to God it's a
LoveHate bipolar Pride being Mexican
being Mexican-American sorry Mexican
americ is a bipolar with
pride and that will get me in trouble
saying it in certain context if I was
any lighter the show would be canceled
the [__] that I say you got to keep the
arms yeah I got to keep the arms like
this hold
on don't oh canceled we're cancel [__]
that video is how I
feel okay there so I I write I write
these things down all the time because I
think on stage it'd be kind of funny to
go
hey a hirs of Mexicans can mean a lot of
things yeah it just keep going because
it's true okay um continue Marty I have
a I have a couple guys I just write
these little things out just want to
throw them out there I can't wait to see
people doing these it's going to be
really
annoying these open mics are going to be
[__] nothing now I offensive I'm
going to point but hey shut up and
they're not saying [__] that's my thing
like thas he goes on just shut up start
scold the audience get sh yeah for real
put your hands on your get off your
phone oh
no I hope not but I'm going to be
getting some fights if I start open
my that's not good I'll tell a [__] to
put her stupid phone away in a second
put your stupid [__] ass phone away
[__] I run a hell of business on there
I'm not on
it nobody need to know what you drank
right now stupid it's really the only
place where that's accepted though where
you could just really go on somebody and
the room just gets behind
you I'm going to bring powder in my my
pocket and just smack the [__] out of
somebody in the front row like in how
high I'm be the first person to do skits
plant [__] like hey you're
going to pretend just do some stupid
[__] sorry I'm not giving away all my
[__] ready
continue
this I was in LA the other day and I
passed by you guys ever see I know
you've seen you walk go by a little
small house and or mobile home and in
the patch of dirt or fake grass in front
of that mobile home it says psychic now
open it's always a hand with a ball or
an outline of a woman with like a thing
on her head and a gown it's always some
cheesy clip art [__] that you know she
probably was a hooker or something it's
weird it's always weird you see him and
if you're in Mercedes right off 99 she's
been there for
years
so I passed by a really nice ass house
the other day a mansion of a house guys
a baller ass house the yard to the door
the street to the door was 50 yards you
know a baller house and in the front of
that lawn what did it say in the gate so
it wasn't like somebody walked by
psychic
open the [__] that owns that house is a
psychic she can only see the real estate
future I've decided that if that [__]
has that house she's the only person
using it to her advantage and went no no
I don't need to know he your father is
what is the market going to be like in
2008 and this [__] just crushed it
there's no other way and then I'm
thinking whoa where's that skit psychic
walking through like your husband's
going to cheat on you you should get a
smaller place like oh damn [__] could
you imagine this [__] like actually we
should go to the other house he's going
to kill you in this house he's not going
to like it here he's going to murder you
here we should go to the next house what
a what a SC what a stupid Cartman
reality show that's some South Park [__]
have ever seen it I just thought
like if you're a
psychic all of you are always living in
Mobile Homes you couldn't see the future
and be like invest a little [__] if
you're not balling out of control what
business do you have being a psychic
right [__] thank you your cards that you
bought at Santi
alley the mass-produced cards from
Mexico got magic I don't know about that
man just stop buying your [__] at Sant
alley and just go be a seamess nobody
needs more psychics we don't we don't
need them you want to prove to me your
psych psychic let's go over to my bookie
all
right [__] figure this thing out all
right how many punches is Sean shiken
GNA land next week [__] that's how I
feel about psychics I don't trust you
unless you tell me some [__] that you
can't
know anyway I don't know how psychic got
this house it must have been like she's
a shitty niece and then like her grandma
died I see one every time in like East
LA when I drive past the five and every
time I think what the [__] is that a
front for how could they possibly afford
this being a [__] psychic on a dead
end Street in East LA every building in
Los Angeles is computer generated
there's only so many tap ayaki and
Korean barbecues there's only so
many immigration tax paper income tax
places in the world I've walked into
these places none of them know how to do
any of this [__] they walk in
go oh [__] these [__]
remember in Truman opens that door and
people on break yeah yeah that's what
most of the [__] is I promise you I
promise dude I've been to a lot of
places there's only so many Alo Locos
that are real I swear if I go up and I'm
a walk and try to open one of these
doors like Grand Theft Auto and it's one
of the buildings you just can't go in I
feel like that all the time like no no
no no no how come your store just says
water yeah it just says water it's so
expensive how has everybody figured this
[__] out how are you paying for this
this random little storefront
alterations there's 96 Grand Mexican
grandmas in downtown that do alterations
yeah the lady charged me 12 bucks that's
only person in
there rents
4,000 you're not making
rent I I swear one organization owns it
all was like you you do that you can do
that you can do that just give me a
little bit of money this is a tax write
off I'm never going to make my money
back M because there's no way water MH
water immigration they're all the same
it's like going through Grand Theft Auto
and you take a right turn you take a
right turn you take a left you take it's
the same store you can only go into the
clothes and clucking Bell it's kind of
like that uh was that New York City that
clip you were showing me earlier the
underground tunnels I don't know if we
should be getting into that it's kind of
religious but you see that stuff that
happened yesterday where they went under
certain churches and there was
underground tunnels with people living
in them fully decked out in the gear
from the
church what creepy it's creepy no matter
what what's going on
like it's not a normal thing to do
man no matter what I'm not saying
anything about
you if you ever want have you ever seen
a dude in full religious like in 2024
you see a guy in a full like uh you like
we had
Friars at the school I went to that the
priests were [__] Friars friers isn't
that like the big coat with a string
yeah they wear like [__] like what
I'm wearing right now and [__] like but
Brown and like they're very [__]
creepy looking and they take super
seriously yeah exactly but like a bathro
but they deliver any
evil but to be down there in some sort
of ceremony underground with some guys
uh dress like that would make it extra
[__] creepy for sure extra underneath
the church so it's like what are the
odds somebody's gonna come down
here I don't like it don't like that at
all also speaking of religion no I'm
just kidding it's about a holiday so I
thought about this the other day I had a
mask I got the mask from they live and I
thought remember being a kid and school
like Halloween was on a school day and
it wasn't Friday you're like oh okay at
least today's going to be sick what
happened on Halloween day I just want to
talk to America again on Halloween if
you're under in fifth grade you know
under eighth grade it's the best day of
the year you go to school there's cob
webs and fake bugs and people are
dressed like Sonic fools are dressed
like the Power Rangers I am actually Ace
Ventura today I can move my ass and no
one's going to get in trouble I can say
crazy [__] and no one's GNA get me in
trouble I can say terrible thing I'm Dr
Evil I can do whatever I want
Halloween's incredible as a kid at
school then what do you do you don't do
any work you got no homework you don't
do any tests you do Halloween crossw
word puzzles the teachers dress like a
[__] Witch uh what else you get to
eat candy at every [__] classroom on
a regular you walk in here's your [__]
homework on the next day yo here's
Twizzlers go sit down and have fun don't
listen to me today and then you know
what we're going to do no lunch we're
all having a pizza party today every
classroom has a pizza party today you
know what you're going to do after
school's out on time you're going to get
picked up you're still dressed as
Sonic right and then what do you do you
meet up with your homies and you go get
as much candy as you can dress as your
favorite character then what do you do
you go home and you [__] annihilate
it if you if you didn't grow up like a
like a poor ass kid sorry no all it's
got to do cool
[__] what do you do you go home you eat
all your candy you go to sleep you wake
up you get to school everyone's dressed
normal and you have homework and you
like the teacher's a [__] again you
can't just do that [__] it's like a
abusive relationship mhm it's like yo I
really like you don't look at me like
that what the [__] is wrong with you the
next day it's back to normal I always
thought about how depressing the next
day after Halloween was think about it
yeah day after Halloween going back to
school is like a adult getting shitfaced
and hung over to work it's the same
shitty feeling you want to just cry and
lay down and dress as Superman there
there's nothing else to it bro so that's
that's it that's it that's all I was
thinking about the April
[Laughter]
Halloween that's fair that's it uhhuh gr
day to the worst
day that's trash yeah I never really
thought about that never really thought
about it that
way all right by the time like you think
like you spent all this money on
Christmas and [__] you think it's made
such a lifelong [__] impact on your
kids then they go by the time they go
back to school a week later they [__]
forgot everything they got they
kids don't even [__] talk about
it
no maybe your children when they're
growing up but when I was a child
everything was the coolest and you
talked about it for eight months maybe
it's a poor town maybe maybe well you
were a poor ass town too I'm talking
about my kids now it's different they
got everything at the yeah you remember
trying to watch real TV and watch a car
chase on on FX or whatever that station
was spite TV mhm you can just go on
YouTube and Google like 9-h hour
compilation of cars now it's not fun to
watch wait for America's Fun's own
videos to hope the guy getting hit in
the dick is the guy that Bob Saga
chooses now Rob Deer deck is doing nine
hours of that a day you don't have to
wait for $10,000 prize you know he's
going to get hit in the dick and my
scorpion
now it's not as fun super true yeah it's
not as fun there's no way it's instant
gratification you have a
phone it's instant I smoked a pre-roll
today I didn't feel like
rolling it's not just kids it's me too
okay instant gratification instant
everything needs to happen now Amazon
next day same day right now that's how
the world is right now it's like wait
you put three months into a project
you're you're slipping bro you could
have put out eight projects like it's a
movie like take some time people are
rushing everything everybody can make a
skit in 20 minutes and go viral and then
try to get paid off of it and then when
that doesn't work they just do only fans
only homies only homies oh yeah only
only homies I was talking about the
other
day it's just it's just you and your
your friends [__] I was like I was
like it's just a bunch of homies just
baying and split the money only homies
or what was it only I called it
something only friends only friends like
yo we're broke just like actually we
found out that make a lot of money I
don't know I thought it was real stupid
only fans girls do what they're going to
do guys do what they're going to do run
it strip clubs are cool just virtual
strip club that's fine do your thing I
just thought it'd be funny it's like hey
fool trying to [__] make some money a
what's up you got like a working job
like guess here it's a
job not gonna like
it what's the what's the intro to that
like yo there's the show talk your
friends into horrible things and at the
end go bro you're really going to do
that uh I was
kidding that's it this the whole
show you just ruined
friendships what's up guys thank you for
watching this episode we want to say
thank you so much to one of our sponsors
and this is raw papers as you know raw
papers one of the biggest papers on the
planet you've seen them you've seen the
cones you see them in all the music
videos you see them everywhere your
local smoke shop your pocket your
backpack your friend's table pretty much
if you're in America and you smoke weed
you probably smoked a raw in your
lifetime and if you haven't get ready
because there's a lot of fun stuff this
is the challenge cone 24 in cone this
fits probably 130 140 G now I've rolled
huge joints but I haven't used the cone
yet so maybe we'll see that popping up
pretty soon right here you have the
stage five rockets the cones all sizes
all shapes here it is right here cone
boosters these are infused with turps
this right here lyrical lemonade times
raw so these are Bud wraps these are
literal Bud pressed down into a wrap and
you roll it pretty damn awesome if you
ask me right now go to Raw life2 247 on
Instagram go ahead and let them know the
dope as usual podcast sent you thank you
guys so much for supporting and shout
out to Raw for sponsoring the podcast
remember if you're going to smoke a
paper make it a raw thank you so much
have a dope ass day it's it's 2024
everything's growing we're all doing
better things Marty and I are going to
do our first live show this year not
sure what month but we're planning
things we're see playing it my year we
do our first live show I think it should
be 21 and over I wouldn't like it not to
be but I would love it to be 21 and over
so I can be like yo get under your seat
like oh Opa there's weed under there I
don't know it' be cool but I can't be
just get weed kids so we're going to do
a first live show not sure where we're
going to do it how we're going to do it
Lea improv uh I really I mean my I want
to do a little mini tour to be honest
that's another thing Marty had in mind I
just got to fix my back my back sucks so
I'm fixing it because I I just can't day
two and I'm I'm I'm disabled like yeah
ruin the whole thing you sold me on this
train up the coast cuz my my vision is
you start off in San Diego you hop on
the train and you're it's you're filming
it the whole time and then you stop in
OC or La you do another meet and grease
live show each place we have a guest
come out or whatever and we stop in San
Francisco we stop in Portland Seattle
then we go right over boom do a little
Vancouver adventure with Spencer then
come back on the plan there's a train
where you can rent the car like you can
rent the room and half of its glass so
you can just see the coast the whole
ride sounds epic yeah we're talking
about the Pacific coast too the whole Co
from top to
bottom pretty cool so the live shows all
that stuff we're we're we're getting
into it this is the year I say I don't
care give me a microphone I'm going go
talk shut up thanks yeah I think that's
going to be a complete Game Change for
your whole life like you really dedicate
once twice a week I mean for the average
person trying to it depends where you're
trying to take
I want to have fun with it make some
fools laugh and if it blows up and does
great so be it and if it doesn't I go
hey man sometimes I like to go the carge
store just [__] yeah that's fun it's
nice when it's not like all your eggs
are in that basket oh no I couldn't be
doing this like thing is with me I like
to do things so good and perfect that
you can't talk [__] about it I'm not
good and perfect at that so it's kind of
scary to me MH yeah yeah you got to just
go uh like get a couple under your belt
but don't even let anybody know like
four five 6 7 8 9 10 then kind of start
just show up I just got to get my [__]
down cuz I like to rant and not
everybody knows everything I'm talking
about so I have to go so what I mean by
that that's just a conversation I don't
need to do a conversation on stage I
think once you do do that it's GNA it's
going to be a lot easier for the world
to understand who we are like be like CU
now it's like yes it's podcast yeah we
dudes but it's like once you get a
legitimate like credits in comedy it's
different yeah this is the year uh I'm
going to go I told you about it I'm
going to go get an agent this year I'm
going to go try to do some acting [__]
this year this is the year I actually do
[__] I need to start doing stuff I'm
over here sitting just going what we
have now is great I know there's other
lanes out there I know there's more
stuff we could be doing talking to Jay
Johnson about the movie [__] like what
yeah I could do that all right can
Flores I just went up there pool thought
it was tight like every comic that's
ever [__] talked to us says the same
words M start I'm just try it out I got
hooked every single person ever every
single one says I just got
hooked so that for me it's like dude
I've had 10 years of people going yo
that was tight which is awesome and fun
but I think something outside of you
have a YouTube channel no I don't I'm
just on stage with you right now what's
going
on yeah I don't care about staging
anymore Ted
Talk extracted that [__] M and like just
having the experience of the podcast now
like different talk there's yeah there's
no like real fear of like falling on
silence and [__] cuz you're already
[__] faced that every episode yeah
like if I need to talk a little bit in
between the [__] if I forget where I'm
going and I got to loop back around and
find my [__] Point again over here I
comfortable knowing I can do that I like
going to real show or to to live shows K
Flores he had this guy from
Ireland nice and the Fool's like you
guys don't like me huh there a Mexicans
he's like it's mexic
the way he was talking he goes I don't
give a [__] I'll Stand quiet for a
minute you was that bad it was funny oh
no he was [__] when people like come on
I don't care if you don't like it cuz
some people were laughing some people
weren't but people are laughing were
dying because it was it was hysterical
but some people didn't get that why it
was so damn funny is because he's so not
a Mexican the fact that he's in this
room is so [__] crazy he's like I'm
from Ireland I've Liv you for two years
the way he was talking like
what and he goes I don't care [__]
you all I bitched out I can only make 30
seconds you won but like just that going
like oh I can do whatever I
want this is mine right here and up
there all right that's all I got to work
with right now [__] you so like keep
going get it did you watch Joe ky's
violent
bombing I only I was on the treadmill
this morning I went Joe Koy Golden
Globes cuz you said it was bad and
people riing them apart I only watch him
talk to Merill Street for 10 seconds and
then I got a call yeah I think it was
Goofy what did he do well I think it was
[__] Goofy for everybody to be so
butt hurt about him making some [__]
basic ass day one Barbie big boob jokes
some [__] about Barbie being based
around uh just a girl with big boobs or
some [__] okay exactly what it whereas
it was up against a movie that was based
on a [__] book and all this history
and [__] that was really the premise of
the joke that I wait did Barbie win
Awards I have no idea but you that movie
was yeah there's a stray dog out there
shit's everywhere better than Barbie
better than Barbie I I'll watch that
[__] again I'll watch do take a [__]
every day it's insane to like get butt
hurt over basic ass jokes like that but
also from the clips that I watched it
just felt like he was bombing in real
time but you can't you can't let a guy
you can't have a guy bomb because your
butt hurt over some basic ass did he
bomb or did you just offended yeah but
like the whole room just by the looks on
the people's [__] faces was like oh I
just saw tweet replies like people
ripping him apart he's an arena see in
my mind also what can happen is you get
to a level in comedy where you're like I
do Arena I'm huge and he's somebody who
came up through the podcast I've did
10,000 joeoy thumbnails like he's been
through all of them yeah dude I used to
I saw him in San Jose they invited me to
a show and I told you like some play was
like trying to get comedies if I post it
like yo come down just post it give you
te I'm like all right Joe qu Matt R
2014 you see Ken Flores posted up there
F yeah yeah it made me laugh out [__]
loud I think I was in the grocery store
I went fat R I love this [__] guy
yeah it was Matt R cuz when I saw Matt R
popping I go that's that kid his looks
different but that's the same kid from
San Jose I didn't realize he got new
teeth oh he used to have smaller teeth
now he's got like veneers oh that's the
same kid I didn't realize it was the
same guy because he looked obviously he
looks different he was 19 just I know
pretty young that's how you started like
I know can't drink like that's how you
start like this guy's funny I like him
like maybe he'll be doing some [__] in
here from for eight years and he just
popped out the biggest community of the
year yeah you know so I saw him with
jokoy did you watch his special Matt re
special I have weird it was weird in
that
it was kind of just like a complaint
session
about like where he was at in his career
really yeah
oh it was a big [__] rant the whole
special was really yeah is it a new
special newer oh so not the one he blew
up off of I haven't seen that I I want
to watch that one too yeah yeah yeah oh
no I I think he's a funny dude he's very
fast like mhm that [__] is just in the
crowd you said that that that was fast
you G people huh he's a while now you
got to be kind of quick even though I
think that [__] scripted I think he got
he got annoyed that he was known as like
uh like the goodlooking like the
comedian that girls like take it yeah I
know but you got [__] definitely take
that sorry [__] want to bang you yeah
like it's like no I'm the real rapper
I'm not just the rapper all the [__]
want to [__] like I got bars no [__] y
I'll be I don't give this [__] if every
guy in the world was like I hate your
comedy but like don't worry like where's
my girlfriend she's here now I'm a
millionaire and I'm nice if you're a
nice person and you're balling don't
worry by the end of the year how many
Ballin Rich famous people are going to
be left that aren't [__] canceled in
jail forever you know what's crazy I
think about it sometimes I'm
like I'm good I'm so happy that I'm not
a creep
yeah God for not wearing me as a creep
thank you for not doing that to me thank
you for not like letting me do stupid
[__] I think being a creep is a choice
though for a lot of people also uh yeah
it's a [__]
Choice opt into that CH yeah dude it's a
choice I mean some people like you got s
story is if he goes I think it's a
choice because he has no idea how to be
a piece of [__] well I'm thinking some
kids are definitely born pieces of [__]
but what's the
ratio they're [__] like a 5% I've met
some kids when we were in third grade
I'm like I don't understand why you suck
so bad I told you the story I had to
punch that kid in the head but some kids
are just weird and some kids have the
weakest parents of all time some some of
you guys out there I'm sorry if you grew
up that way some some of your parents
suck and some of them put that [__] into
your brain so it's not just you you can
grow out of it I know some ignorant ass
fools that are now not as ignorant
because they grew up and let it just let
it happen just just be good all right
just be nice to be good to people
because it's G to come back whether or
not it's in Ellen
form or like Jimmy Fallon
form either way just be cool because
every person that you hire that you
think is not [__] has a voice and
they're humans like if you're just nice
off the bat you would never have to
worry about having to be nice on camera
or off so I'm glad this is the year that
everyone gets [__] on everyone that's
doing bad things it's going to come to
light I feel it this year I'm being a
little
more open you know I did the clear of
the air episode we did this episode we
talking about a bunch of [__] stuff
that's uncomfortable hey man sometimes
I'm going to be uncomfortable doing open
mics I'm going be uncomfortable people
heckling me I'm going be uncomfortable
having a not get pissed but I got I got
to get there something's got to change I
got to do something else I know there's
more to it like Simon bur there's more I
know I'm me here for you know what I can
say it I'm such an arish sha feir fan I
told you then he said that [__] about
Kobe and I I pretended he didn't exist
anymore because it really bugged me that
you would do like that I get it that's
your stick
but bro no not cool I don't care about
[__] like that at all and that what are
you smoking this is some [__] I had
no no no what is that where did you get
that that I took a little puff off this
over the weekend so it looks like joints
right here no this is plat emoji that
shit's covered in ashes I took a little
you put it out and the ashes are on it
I'm like did she just pick it up out of
the I thought you got out me and April
went to the hotel for our little
Christmas present or whatever in Dana
Point [__] was
luxurious and had a couple drinks we
went out on this patio in front of the
bar on the hotel and I [__] [__]
spark this [__] up oh
no just to realize like oh I'm basically
boxing this whole [__] restaurant
yeah what are you
doing what the [__] is wrong with you I
had a couple drinks damn when Marty has
a couple drinks he's back in Buffalo
full sparked it in doors OG what's wrong
with you it was outside but there was
Windows there was a porch you know I
know I can tell that that's your joint I
mean you hit joints hard they're
suctioned you know when you a seal food
and it's starting to
go and it gets tight over the food
that's what Marty's joints look like cuz
he's hitting it so hard it pulls the
paper to the creases of the paper I to
the Joint I love looking at it it's so
funny you V you're vac sealing that [__]
well whatever you want we have a
plethora of joints thank you zic so
whenever you
ready I know I never smoke joints
outside of here I know so I gra me a
little pre-roll I'm like we're going to
be walking around and [__] first first
of all it was [__] freezing like it
is Arctic air out there you just said
that I know I know it is Mary just broke
he officially just got cold yo we went
to the Bills game that sh was cool yeah
you oh we haven't talked about that yeah
went to an actual Bills game him and
Josh Allen did not me I subed in for
Josh nobody noticed nobody noticed I
threw a couple
[Laughter]
picks why you such a Bills fan uh I did
that I I those Pig I threw a couple
pigs almost gave me a goddamn heart
attack it's one the worst teams in the
league who they play chargers chargers a
City without a team how are we going to
have 98% Bills fans in the [__]
Stadium every game that comes to La it's
the other team there is no fan base in
Los Angeles if you wear a Rams jersey
and you're in La you're either a really
really really hardcore fan or whatever
gang you're in rocks that
[__] whatever number you're rocking is
for your gang because that's not
real there's no fans here it's sad dude
it's weird like it's weird one of the
Chargers fans was talking [__] and two
rows in front of us I'm like I'm I
really was sitting there dissecting in
my mind how they don't belong here
you're going to move up here you guys
don't belong this guy's from Buffalo
right it's like you don't belong here
[__] you you're in an a you're in the
next city over you're going to move up
here where there's already a team and
you got the same goddamn colors as them
similar looking goddamn
logo nobody you got no fans here no
nobody cares it's very weird people that
rock Chargers are the bolts for white
supremacist Michael he got bolts on
it I I feel like their real original
fans probably them anymore right there's
a fan base in San Diego still yeah well
they're not in La not no in San Diego
people like the Chargers man I've been
to a lot of Chargers game my there's
some Chargers die hards out there it's a
city people like it not like a not like
San Francisco LA is even worse though
there's no fan base here dude La doesn't
have like local home PRI [__] they had
it for Raiders right every Sports is
completely stocked there's no Rams
shortage of anything they're they're
there's nothing do you see the Clippers
are getting their own goddamn new Arena
built big ass Arena how it's the
Clippers and the Lakers here right yeah
but nobody I told my dog I was ranting
to my kids about this I'm like she's
like who are the Clippers I'm like
exactly how do they get a billion dollar
Arena like how somebody
got hey man La it's okay we got two
football teams two NBA teams we got uh
the Dodgers we got the Kings and some
crime m winning I cry what the
[__] oh [__] so oh oh oh oh you know
what I realized huh I've only watched
two Joe Rogan episodes I have never
watched full episodes of any
podcast ever damn near except our own
[__] and a few Will Sasso ones I've
watched him start to finish just kind of
got him when he was a guest is too funny
on fire the kid like he's just too
[__] flip this table over let just do
it it's so funny I used that's funny you
say that I've never I've only watched
two Rogan episodes full and as I
realized that I've been watching a lot
of podcast break down you guys know that
and uh 2018 is when I was like dude I
would do a podcast and I Met You in 2020
MH I only watched of Joe Rogan in 2018 I
didn't really know about podcast till
2018 I'm like yo just talking these
fools will just talk for
hours okay I get it Rogan's the a fear
factor for and the UFC guy he's got some
sick ass guests I'm like yo I like
podcast so like when I think about it we
started one three years later triy to
plan it two years
later it was just kind of meant to be
there's a there's a saturation right now
that every there's there's so many shows
it's kind of crazy like the who's
putting up the money for that there's so
many shows I've seen with amazing
sets that are talking about like you
know a niche thing like how are they
making their money back it's not easy
it's not easy at all well also
everybody's not fighting against YouTube
too with the you know all right you're
right you're right you're right you're
right also we're fighting against
YouTube we're demonetized we're all that
you guys know that we're only a couple
million behind some of the biggest shows
can you did we explain to them what
YouTube
did oh yeah like of course you want me
to say it yeah how the irony of our two
months of monetization
ready we got monetized two months ago
Marty and I went o thank you appreciate
it thank you God right right we left
alone and then one day we're sitting
here go ahead YouTube please put yeah
put ads in got oh happy 150 by the way
this is episode
153 yeah we got 153 episodes YouTube go
ahead put some ads in them things yeah
put the ads in appreciate you thank you
for monetizing us actually Marty fast
forward a couple weeks me and you were
sitting in these very chairs and I go
Marty do you set the ads now that we're
monetized cuz we haven't done it in 2
years he goes
no I go no there's 150 episodes uh I
just let them automatically be set what
do we do we check one episode there are
14 ad reads in one episode within 20
minutes YouTube is literally making
people go I'm not watching this there's
14 ads in 20 minutes 30 ads within 30 EP
we put one every 15 minutes for the
first hour and then any hours after
every 20 four hours there's a like a TV
show we try to make it you feel like oh
I'm invested 15c break I'm invested
15sec break oh I'm really invested I'm
already an hour in no do every 20
minutes that's only three an hour three
an episode cuz once there's an hour
we're telling stories that's usually
when the guest is warmed up we think
about this like I don't want to just cut
fools off and go bro the least amount of
ads as possible and when there's ad
reads we'll skip them so we'll we'll
we'll space them off after
that YouTube put quadruple the amount of
ads that we normally do so there's
people out there that have never seen
our
show oh wow fluffy I love fluffy click
it ad 14 ads add 10 seconds goes by
comes back on right I go I'm not
watching this and these guys are garbage
for doing it
I don't like these guys they're greedy
14 ads bro I didn't didn't even cross
our mind what do we do every single
episode we have ever put out ever had 20
plus batteries all day it took us an
hour and a half here two hours at home
and he did it for 3 hours and then what
meaning we went back Episode by episode
deleted all of their ads and manually
added ads in each slide to 15 minutes
you're like
15 30 back to season one episode one
every single one of them and and on
Spotify what happened though what
happened two days later hey guys good
news I know you just fixed All Those ads
good news you're demonetized again
better news because we're demonetizing
this channel we're going to go ahead and
demonetize the clean Clips Channel
also
so the day before that happened Marty
gave me a game plan on hiring somebody
to do Clips yeah and we were going to
pay him with the monetization money it
was going to help but it's okay cuz
we're going to find something else else
to make quadruple that amount of money
watch watch this because we're putting
it out there we're going to make it
happen if we don't we're going to make
happen anyway and what my my main goal
of this year is is to get back to a
place that we've never been which is
just making what we want to make and not
thinking about YouTube When We Make it
yeah not thinking I I just want to make
the best episodes we can make that's all
as far as the best titles the best
thumbnails the best conversations the
best everything that I just want to make
the best show and just burst out of
these goddamn handcuffs that mentally we
got to think about all the time so
whatever it's going to be I want to give
YouTube what it wants this children's
content and uh really continue to grow
in a place that makes sense
Spotify yeah so yeah we're gonna we're
going to that that's like I said I made
a post on Instagram it seem to resonate
with a lot of people we put together
like a four-month plan the first quarter
of the year right before it started then
kind of backed it down month by month
week by week day by day on what it would
kind of take to get to where we want to
be you know specifically kind of
generally over the next quarter and uh
yeah threw a little wrench in it but
it's whatever we're still going to do it
it is funny though they're like no so
funny eight hours then we'll snag it
it's okay it's just kind of funny and
frustrating but it's funny though
because of of course though right yeah
yeah of course I know I laughed after
that laugh laugh like of course man how
much was in there oh we don't get it now
sick all the money we already
accumulated you can't just dump it to us
you're going to take it
away of course do you want some more
yeah I'll pay you want my account when
you're trying to run a business and
scale a business you really need to know
how much you're going to make every
month that's really [__] frustrating
that's the problem it's super cool
though especially when we just put all
this time and effort into growing the
clips Channel up thank you guys like
this kind of was going good but we we'll
see we'll see it's all right what we're
going to do is we're going to innovate
with the short form content on Spotify
you can believe that so these clips if I
can get vertical Clips going on Spotify
we
will by the way guys we had some
technical difficulties with Spotify this
week I don't know if we talked about
this on the show or not already but
thank you for everybody watched on
Spotify cuz we got a massive Outreach of
people pissed off that it was because it
wasn't uploaded that's how we found out
trust me if it's not Spotify there's
some [__] going on that I'm working on
yeah we don't know why this burner
episode
took 18 hours to upload it was a massive
file and Spotify requires a different
file format than YouTube does and the so
I have to reexport the whole video out
at Double the file size for Spotify
Notting and it was this the episode's
three and a half hours long [__] kept
crashing [__] kept timing out when I was
uploading it to Spotify so it was fun we
got a
time yeah [__]
it yo what time is it 10:3 oh shout out
to all the fans I've been bumping into
in public too I've been meeting some
cool ass fans out there Mar's finally
getting hit with the wavs finally going
in public Marty's not just going school
store school well it was just in my
regular life like the one time I was
walking back from the uh [__]
prescription counter at CVS walking down
the aisle and the kids just like oh [__]
just right there in the aisle did the
whole [__] and then I was at the
chiropractor the kid working at the
chiropractor shop oh yeah he knew I was
coming in though he had already peeped
my file he's like I thought it was going
to be you bro I heard your voice I was
like I heard your voice like he like was
saying like Damn Your Voice Sounds like
you like Oh you mean when he met you
yeah I thought you like he was like the
kid then when he looked at your file I
just heard your voice no no no no like
like now that yeah insane it was like
when I met 50 c I remember thinking that
when I met 50 like damn his voice sounds
like his
voice I get
you so this one's not hitting no but it
was cool I ended up just talking to this
kid through my whole chiropractical
adjustment and
[__] sorry guys I just dropped a cherry
on the ground oh no no I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry yeah usually my
job sorry chiropractor appointment yeah
I'm getting you I'm getting better at at
uh I'm getting better at meeting the
fans because I I'm just like I need to
slow down a little bit I I noticed just
in general like
mean slow down in what way like I'm so
uh I like don't want to be in people's
way I don't want to hold people up I
don't want to like do anything I don't
know I just the first couple times I Met
fans I felt like I just kind of slapped
him up and thank you appreciate it and
just dapped him up and kept moving oh oh
got you got and then I felt like [__]
about it but afterwards I was like you
need to slow down this is a really
special moment for them [__] they
listen to you you're like I need to just
think about when it was reversed for me
and like slow down they're not like they
don't want you to run off anywhere chill
the [__] out oh I see what you're saying
yeah of course dude so I take it doesn't
matter how long it
takes yeah 20 minutes yeah like I just I
needed to I needed to learn how to just
yeah I just need a little bit more
experience in that well you'll talk to
people in Earth anyway so like it's
going to take you a minute whether
you're a fan or not but oh thanks man
have a good day now it's like no no no
what's up full thank you how long you
watch the show thank you because you
need to know
like you like you said that was 20 years
ago like when I at 5 C his voice sounds
like a that was a long time ago man yeah
and he's still like yeah hell yeah
because you care like I actually love
that voice [__] yeah and they listen to
you you're you're their Bob and Tom in
the
morning you have to think like dude yes
and you're nice I'm so happy that's all
it matters to me like just be nice to
anyone and everyone I had a kid in
Huntington Beach do
that yeah he was like bro I heard your
laugh came up to me and
[__] I'm just out there chilling with my
kids I was pissing at a stall and guy
goes yo is that Marty O'Neal sup
folks
sh it's [__] funny yeah if you see me
come say what's up take a picture I'll
[__] follow you on Instagram whole
[__] Mar goes hard dude and here's why I
don't follow everyone on Instagram and
people have asked me that you
ready three separate times I have met
people and taken pictures with them
three separate I mean I'm thinking
thousands of pictures three times where
I like they hit me on Instagram you know
sometimes like yo what's your Instagram
yeah type it in and they just hit follow
I'm like
bro don't do that to me
what if you're like a scammer I ain't
trying to follow your [__] let me look
at it at least first damn M that's what
people don't understand like damn you
think you're too cool to follow your fit
you know how many people have used the
picture with me and them to sell
packs I've gotten so many people like
bro this fo says is your homie I go
that's in front of a
store you think I just take pictures of
my homies in front of stores
randomly if like I don't think what he
says your homie he's got p he has a
picture with you like oh my God are you
kidding me a picture with me and then I
went you know what if I was some dude in
the midwest I followed me and I went yo
oh you do know you have a picture with
him all right what's up how much for the
QP all right you're going to ship it cuz
Thomas I know is not a piece of
[__] and then look at now now I'm a
piece of [__] so I don't follow everyone
I don't follow people that have no
profile pictures or posts because the
next post could be a swasa or a dick and
then I'm following somebody that just
posts a dick and has racial [__] and
there you have to think about this this
is a real thing love we think a horrible
[__] it's always like dick or racist
that's two worst things in the world
like don't show me no dick don't show me
no
swash evil
gross both evil and gross depending on
the
situation
um so that's why when Marty was like I'm
gonna follow back everybody on the
podcast I went don't say it considered
that because I called like Marty stop I
went through and there was like 16
accounts that were just Bots and like
four accounts that were does
that pek Ferrari
mention Bitcoin expert like oh no we
follow scammers see we follow some
scammers sometimes no I went through
every single person we follow and anyone
that have a profile picture or a post
gone unless you have stories and if you
have active stories you're just chilling
I'd leave you alone if you don't have a
post but you're using it that's fine I
just don't want to follow a ghost
account that goes tomorrow it's nudes or
something dumb because it's h three
times one time won get two wild but one
time there was a picture right there
somebody from a certain person that came
here once took a picture right there in
front of our [__] to solidify that they
know me and then started selling packs
on t as me a guest no not a guest
somebody that a guest or not a guest
somebody that came here once with a
somebody brought random full here once I
don't let nobody bring nobody [__]
here dude so the fact that I saw that
pissed me off CU I go above and beyond
and not let weird fools here and then
that happened it's like seful come on
man it's my background on my show you
can say it's not me it's just my other
account like it sounds so easy and so
real because you could just say hey fool
what the [__]
yo mhm and then s a picture of this like
oh you're you're in the warehouse you're
in the Ware this the background it's
unbelievably easy to just Photoshop you
in too if you want
to Bro people do it so much that's why I
don't follow random people right off the
bat yeah I follow fans on Twitter I
follow fans on Instagram if we have a
rapport and I'm talking to you and
you're cool if I are you nice and cool I
don't care if you have three follow I
don't give a [__] if I see you leave a
nice comment I do look at the profile
now have to I try to I try to follow a
couple people each day God
you have to
because well my thing is like I keep all
my pages separate like dope was your
life trying to follow a lot of weed
stuff all my other channels maybe I'll
follow cooler like you know cars or this
on the podcast more more Comedians and
people at first it was just people we
want on the show remember that and then
we got to you know [__] that I have
follow this I have follow this company I
follow who cares but remember I have all
the accounts on my phone if I'm
like there's 700 pig people I've never
even seen her man I don't know what they
do
why did I follow these accounts man I'm
I'm I'm trying to get off my phone I
want to see what everybody's doing that
day and be done cuz I like seeing that
[__] I like going through and liking
everybody's [__] that I think is doing
cool [__] or on YouTube I don't watch
everybody's YouTube channel but I always
press like all we tubers I press like on
their videos because it [__] helps so
I'll go through and just I don't I just
need I just I don't need to watch it to
know that I like you you're ready going
to do something good you're not going to
do some [__] that's why so for me
it's different cuz people will people
will try to use that [__] it's happened
so many so many [__] times and it's
annoying sorry that's why that was a
long rant but that's why I'm very
cautious with that [__] so dumb dude
people really like I know you say it all
the time you won't you don't s but I
believe this fake accounts is
you you know it's okay it's all right
it's actually [__] insane it's insane
but here we
are um so the reason I brought up
podcasting damn that was a long 25
minutes ago this is not this is just I
think it's
clogged Sor right look
at oh there it
goes it was pack too tired at the top
the reason I brought a podcast in 2018
all this stuff the sober October the
Rogan used to do all the time right
everybody gets in better shap they stop
drinking they stop smoking I'm not going
to do that smoking and drinking I don't
drink but I ain't stop smoking [__] you
um it's January Marty I wanted to do
something for us and I know a lot of
people like well you just bite so no you
can look at things go I loved the way
they did that and I love what it did for
people I would like to do something
similar this is not like a whole
challenge thing this is accountability
thing you want to do kickboxing get
Hella buff I need to not be fat
I've already all my [__] I know you say
all the time well want a way L Dre my
back is getting better I got on the
tread two days in a row you had to you
had to I had to fix this first but it's
the past five months my back is getting
better I can feel it it still hurts but
I can move I can squat I can bend I can
do this I
can I can be active I'm on the treadmill
I can get down into a push-up position
now before my back would seize it was so
crazy I thought I was like you fat lazy
bastard you don't want to do no push-ups
your back hurts like no I was wondering
why I was shooting pigs into my skull
it's my spine like I was always one like
you're such a [__] what was why is your
head hurt that little bat that shot me
with that [__] huh trying to do a pushup
like struggling wondering why my bag is
locked up now I'm okay I'll just do some
girl push-ups bro I don't care so this
is what I'm saying for everyone out
there whether it's yo I want my
landscaping business to be better damn I
really need my Deli to start popping
uh comments bro leave it in the comments
update us every month all right every
time we do a solo episode we will bring
this back every month once a month I'm
going to update you guys um I don't know
how I don't feel like
that if you met me in person I'm a I'm a
I'm not a skinny I'm a big person like
I'm but I'm not like job of the Hut I
can't do [__] well I can I'm a be an
athlete I can do things my back hurts
but I can do [__] I'm actually a strong
person I'm extremely strong weight like
I'm [__] a freak of nature for that
reason and
uh I'm not anymore I can't even bench
280 I couldn't go hit 280 right now to
save my life I could here and this would
start to pull I already know I couldn't
hit 280 to save my life I couldn't squat
350 right now my back's messed up I
can't run a mile in under 8 minutes
right now I used to be able runs six 7
Minute miles all the time I was I was
active so this is for me to you for
whatever you're doing like yo January
update me month one my business I was
doing this oh [__] February I'm up 8% I
want to see by next January the end of
the year I'm going to calculate I want
to follow you I want to see your cu the
same people are commenting all the time
there's more I just found the channel
love the community that's that's the
best there's people in there like do
second year here
148 episodes with you like saw that a
lot on the bur episode Watching since
2018 for this the whole time exactly
people are people are you guys are real
people we are real people if there's
podcast out there I get it there's a lot
of celebrities have podcasts a lot of
comedians have podcasts a lot of people
are cool people a lot of people are real
people I'm not trying to like say we're
awesome I'm saying in the podcast World
we're we are we are normal ass fools
making a show every time it's about to
start Marty I go
wait it's going out to let going out to
people all right let's get ready what
are we going to say today all right cool
we had minor notes you know we had three
screenshots
Mexicans joke Mexicans it says husband's
going to murder you in here that's all
it says if you can see the notes
sorry they're very minimal there're just
talking points but that [__] looks
ridiculous this [__] really knew the
market was going to change
that was me on the 99 or no uh on the
118 coming home going this [__] really
knew the market huh should leave these
up from Mario Lopez comes
through it's a horrible [__] everywhere
Mexican jokes oh all Mexican
jokes oh oh yeah Mario Lopez coming very
soon might be might be this Following
episode yeah it might be this Following
episode guys we are legitimately talking
like crushing it child to his team
they're the most like see that access
the bottom that was weird yeah this like
talking to his team his Hollywood logo
like oh
[__] get game game point a game face on
sorry what the [__] are we talking about
oh we're we're normal ass fools we're
just chilling we're we're having fun
Marty and I we never interviewed people
before so you're growing I'm growing I'm
trying not to interrupt fools Marty's
talks 99.9% more than he used to in
season
1 like I mean there's a lot of things
are changing things are going I like it
all of it's for the better I'm trying
not to interrupt fools as much anymore
it's just sometimes I'm like oh yeah
[__] he's talking what are you saying
shut up I'm doing better though season
one I can't even watch some of them they
annoy the [__] out of me just looking at
me go shut up fool a Ryan sickler when
the first guest second guest I'm like he
was saying something oh yeah know
totally understand I'm like Jo shut up
he was literally G making a point you
grow we're potheads we talk in the
garages over each other we're all high
as hell talk fing I'm not used to this
I'm a one guy talk show story time I'm
not used to
Breaking like with the uh First Franklin
episode big big lessons like I biggest
takea away from me was that first
Franklin episode that it haunts me you
guys you should due diligence on the on
guests when they have like the newest
[__] coming out because we didn't know
his newest thing coming out because we
wanted to go deep and that's before I'm
like these guest is coming on here to
show the case what they're doing and
their most current thing is their most
passionate thing yeah so why not talk
about the most passionate thing we were
like we we'll find out about it during
the interview they'll tell us but just
like no you need to know going in now we
know that yeah now we know that the
first Frank thing shot me in the face it
hurt me so bad when he said that
one [__] he wasn't being a dick he was
like oh just you know you got he's just
older brothering us you guys future
reference new sh know my [__] yeah like
you guys thought you're doing a great
job here technically like you're really
[__] up right now you need to be
doing all this 30
seconds that [__] haunted me bro it hurt
my chest for
yeah weeks every time I watched the
piece like where we didn't do our job
right just getting all sick like this is
me on going up and stand up not knowing
what I'm saying that was the same
feeling
like I'm not going to even do this then
why do I even do this I'm not going to
do it great
[__] like that you there's so much you
don't know until you do it that's why
and I will my main thing this year is
putting out my my course and coaching
program and that's a huge element of it
you don't know a lot of this [__] until
you get out there and get into it like
there's so many things that you would
never think of or like you might not
even like you know how how do I format
show notes what's the best way to get
prepared for an episode stuff like that
like 10 10 things that can are highly
likely to go wrong 10 things that can go
wrong that can ruin everything a tiny
little insignificant little misstep or
misc that literal Ru the entire episode
one time Marty misstepped on a cord and
we lost half of our audio for a whole
episode who was it for my mom mom yeah
4our episode half of it got T because we
stepped on a cback
accident little [__] like that now it's
you look around every cord is [__]
taped
down now nothing moves it's not coming
apart that was a sad day yeah that was
terrible not bad
but just in the chat going it's cuz this
it's cuz this 600 times was wait it out
just wait it out wait it out coming soon
8 minutes left 4 minutes two hours in
we're good
a um so what I was saying back back to I
was
saying January all right we're starting
off whatever Marty your goal like I said
if you're like yo I'm I'm almost a
teacher update us every month we go
through the comments so this is what's
going on 1,000 comments is a lot we're
trying our best bro we're trying our
best sometimes it takes me it takes
three days to get them used to be the
first day we just do th we just have
five hours straight five hours straight
anymore is just so much for any of the
businesses it's like no no no delegate
that [__] if it's going to take you five
hours with the premier the live and the
comments yeah then it's a full day
Premiere filming doing the live doing
the comments you're at 18 hours not incl
the edit that is 25 20 hours you know so
um that's what I'm saying I'm leave it
in there I will leave it in this in this
episode I'm GNA leave it at the bottom
guys we're starting off all right I I
had to go to the doctor I like I said
earlier I'm relatively like athletic
that's where I go off that was 19
minutes ago I'm
324 pounds they weighed me and I looked
at it and went
what you
serious God it's like I'm a hollow thing
and they just filled me up with like
lead that's how I feel like yo stop for
Real where is
that yeah I guess so you I look down
like all right like a rhino like a
rhino's leg I get it all right it
doesn't bend that way all right yeah
okay the legs are definitely heavy and
I'm
like [__] I'm fat oh [__] and then I see
the din I go what did you just say that
is just That's not healthy or good all
right we're starting it off I'm not
ashamed to say it [__] I you can
see it I'm not in shape I I I'm I'm
getting better though my bag is getting
better um I swore it off
again you guys know like once I say I'm
not going to do things I'm not going to
do things anymore I don't do Coke
because I don't do Coke anymore I
stopped drinking soda eight months ago
cuz I said I can't keep doing it I
slipped my uncle John died I using an
excuse to go I'm going drink a Coke For
You full chugg didn't just
went like Jimmy got a blast and it goes
through his brain that's how it went
through my whole body and
just remember in uh You Ever Seen The
Fifth Element with Bruce Willis are you
[__] kidding me no of course not it's
Bruce Willis Chris Tucker Milo jovic oh
yeah I know I know the poster Gary man
mhm you should watch it's great movie
you you would you would love it I'm sure
I would no it's like a it's a [__]
really fun sick movie it's dope as hell
you should watch it damn it doesn't make
sense anymore anyway I'm going to scream
a ball of light out of my mouth save the
Earth that's how I feel sometimes but I
I'm I'm full of that I don't know why
I'm so damn heavy but I'm going to fix
it all right we're getting here and I'm
saying that I know there's going to be
like 900 people like damn bro you worry
about too much about the weed you're
over three I just told you [__]
I understand so there's no reason like
you need to Lo that's what we're talking
about you're not a doctor and if you are
give me some advice on glue gluten cuz I
am allergic so the reason I say I'm
stopped is because I stopped doing the
soda damn did you hear that mhm y I'm
running laps around this [__]
thought the way my thoughts work are the
the thing at Taco Bell when you're a kid
you put the coin in and it goes in the
water and you have to land on thing you
get a free
Taco here's my point yeah here's seven
other things and I'm just dropping like
oh [__] yeah that's right I'm trying to
lose weight that's right that's right
Fifth Element
and we're over here Forest Gump Forest
Gump Forest they're all the top six or
Forest Gump that's how my brain works
the prize at the Taco at the Taco
Bell I was making a funny ass meme uh
cuz how burner kept saying how he was
like yeah for come remember the scene
where they're crossing the Mississippi
River and there's the two dudes
interviewing Forest as he's running yeah
I had a sick ass little meme halfway
going you burner Forest me and you
interviewed
oh I love that
see that's the [__] all the funniest
Rogan flips you've ever seen from this
guy's brain so it's really funny you got
to start doing that [__] again every
time Marty makes one of us people love
it every single time and we keep it on
the page because it does so well every
single time actually they're funny
um the [__] was I saying oh Taco Bell
brain yeah hold yourself accountable
hold me accountable I'm in there I'm
going to go drop updates boom January
bam this is it February drop it in there
you could do the same use my format boom
January this is where we're at this is
where we're at see you next month keep
up with us guys I want to see some like
I said I don't care whether it's I need
to put on weight I need to start my
business I need to go to school one
semester down boom 3.1 like bro that
[__] matters we give a [__] I hope you
do better update us so we can stay on
track I just want to you know what I'm
saying like we're we're with our fans
all the time m d a Taco Bell thing that
was a long time ago same people are
almost in the comments but there's new
people oh my God that was that long ago
[__]
okay that's what I want to do so what we
whatever let's come up with a name with
it let's come up with a name like what
was it accountability buddies from South
Park so the the when they were uh going
to G pray the gay away camp it's called
a cill buddy but the kid kept we we were
going to get flagged for these never
mind you should watch the episode he
kept not being alive all the kids kept
not being alive
and they're called accountability
buddies maybe that's what it should be
called accountability
buddies accountable buddies
o maybe it was high Miss mistaking
that's they s good maybe that's what
they called it and I'm just like yeah I
flipped it I didn't flip it I think it
was a cannabella buddies anyway let's
make up a name let's do it this year
it's 2024 guys I'm excited I'm ready I'm
ready to my back is getting fixed
Marty's house is done that has been a
chapter since episode one that is now
closed we talked to people that we never
thought we would talk to or have on the
show we got AC Slater coming I you know
what's crazy what got me this morning it
made me
go somebody made a fake Adam Sandler
profile went yo would love to be on the
show and DM me this morning
a piece of
[__] piece of [__] it had like 80
followers I looked at like this
and like no check mark oh I don't care
look a there's no post on that page just
a profile picture don't do that to me
don't hyped me up like that I got all
juic this morning
Mari I was I was saddened a it broke my
heart when I eyes finally calculated
going I could see that went back to
sleep I check I check all I look at them
shits I like flash real quick to see if
anything cracking yeah dude I get so yo
go to DMS press top requests MH I an
[__] they a monster huge outside of
the weed companies that had been hitting
me up for weeks months would love to
work with you love the show I'm
like they could pay for this building
what am I doing yeah I'll talk to you
after but like I
gotta I got to start looking at my DMs
ones with the check I usually don't care
cuz it's always some you know what I'm
saying if you get a bunch of DMS it's
like I'm talking to the fans I see hey
love the videos I answer that [__] I
don't really answer the DMS of business
because Instagram is always flagging me
I'm like I don't want to DM you back
you'll love to work get deleted because
it's promotional like I leave that [__]
be most of the time oh okay that's why
you don't see a lot of sponsors on my
channel anymore I just kind of left it
go let it go but I'm back I made a new
deck I started reaching out to people
for the first time in my life never
reached out to a company ever now I'm
reaching out like hey by the way hey
check it out by we can work together let
me know never done that in my life I
always let things come to me but now I'm
like I got to get after it no one's
going to be at The Comedy Store go yo
I've watched your video get up here it's
not going to happen I got to go do this
[__] like I like yo your back's going to
get better you're going to lose weight
bro he going to get better how how are
you going to lose weight you don't do
anything your back hurts you can't run
oh maybe I should just get on the [__]
every morning and walk and start eating
that [__] ass salad I say that [__] was
not good MH it was trash hate a salad I
love salads and that one was D
anyway I'm trying oh I sore it off
that's what I'm getting back to my uncle
John died I'm like this this one's for
you then for two and a half years
straight I just drank soda and I
realized I look at the picture from that
day I put on 40 50 pounds of just soda
weight damn it Marty have you seen me
from season
1 it's a lot more defined and I went
that's soda
we wow and Juice cuz I cuz I wouldn't
drink anything out of a bottle or a can
that was my thing thing when I move down
here done no more bottles or cans
because it means it can be preserved
that means it's not real that means it's
never going to mold why is it liquid
molding I want nothing to do with the
liquid that isn't mold bro like that's
what's supposed to happen it's liquid
yeah so I went n nothing out of a caner
bottle or nothing it has to be straight
from a press from a juice or water and
I'm done so I started that two days ago
here we are my protein shake tastes like
[__] with just water a watered protein
shake hell water protein powder and
fruit I put a shitload of fruit in it
it's not good I mean it sounds
disgusting I make mine with almond milk
and it's basically the same [__] because
now I'm like dude I'll take shots of
vodka and I'll take shots of tequila but
I won't take a shot of some water to get
my protein like that's how I got to
start thinking like bro do it it's good
for you I'm starting to think like when
I walked in I was like it's cold I
haven't felt like [__] it in a while I
used to go I don't care I'm used to I'm
walking in or with no no jacket
[__] but then I got comfortable with no
bro got get a jacket you have a
wareh who cares bro that's how I feel
now I'm like let's just start filming my
my film room I move this week so my film
room gets back in my house this week
having TR come tomorrow to set up the
light set up all my [__] I'm going start
filming in my room start filming like I
always used to the first story time was
no camera man it was no two cuts it was
just me and the camera and me talking
[__] now I can start doing daily updates
go live from my camera like hang out I
have my own space I don't have to drive
all a 35 minute drive to this Warehouse
to film in that room anymore I bought
the same camera you have so I can film
myself and I hav it filmed myself I
don't know what I'm
doing the fck am I doing it's overrun I
don't want a weed room anymore I don't
want a a toy room anymore did tell I put
all that [__] away yeah you kind of
aired all this [__] out in Story Time
Rec right F film dude like I'm I just
need to film my [__] it needs to be cool
I want you guys to see a sick background
on Twitch and stream dreams and all that
[__] and go thank you for finally doing
the [__] I watched who ninja was Ninja
the fortnite guy so the downfall of
ninja I didn't know who the [__]
was he was getting 220 million views on
YouTube a month damn to four now
four but the reason I brought it up is
because this dream room was sick that's
what I need why can't I just open the
door and go this is where I feel like
when you do here every time you open the
door people go oh damn I'll do that at
my own home why not I have all the stuff
just set it up I'm just busy but am
I accountabil buddies all right this is
January Marty you drop it in there too
whatever you're trying to accomplish
this year let's all get in on it um if
you have but be consistent please let's
be consistent I'm going to be updating
you guys on my Snapchat my Twitter
Marty's got his Twitter he's got his I
don't my Tik tok's locked but I'm trying
to get out of it I just we need to be on
on each other we need to be on each you
guys are our friends we're all friends
one thing we don't do is uncomfortable
[__] we don't talk about uncomfortable
things on the show we don't bring up
people and talk we didn't ask jezy about
Gucci man we didn't ask ad about Adam
Adam 22 we could have easily asked all
of these we didn't ask steo what's up
with bam how come you guys are treat why
is he in the new movie we could have
done all these every guest we could go
after that every single thing and get
that [__] and we can get it at but
that's not who we
are but but kind of I kind of want to
know I kind of want to know but also I
don't want to make you feel
uncomfortable I want you to leave here
going those guys are cool I actually
don't give a [__] about that anymore I
want to get the best interview out of a
person that I could possibly can the
burn interview I was very quiet because
I didn't know I told you I didn't know
how to feel about him yet it's the first
time we've ever spoke real talk in
person and Marty I was kind of letting
Marty just kind
of I was glad he was looking at you and
you asked the question I was kind of
like waiting and just interjecting
interjecting I was trying not I was
trying to just let it it breathe let it
be you tell your stories I'm going
to sit back a little bit yeah just cuz I
wasn't sure it's the first time we've
ever had a guess that I wasn't like yo
I've watched this full all the time we
got no problem this is the first time
like oh we have a little problem we got
to figure it out now that we figured it
out I feel so much better everything's
just I just feel so much better about it
more opportunities for everybody just to
be happy I don't have to avoid people
where like in advance we just like avoid
each other and [__] like it doesn't have
to be that way and I'm so glad it's not
but I held myself accountable I was like
no let's get this [__] done let's stop
being
so little [__] about this I may just
say it when it could be so big for the
whole Community for the everybody's so
excited about I'm excited I loved
hearing these stories like I love Rosie
has never listened to burner before
because she's been with me she didn't
know who burner wash and I was like H
what's wrong with this guy she he don't
like you or something like I know I
don't know if I'm listen to him anymore
I feel kind of weird listening to a guy
that like personally doesn't like me but
now I know that wasn't the thing it was
a whole misunderstanding she's never
listen to him because we've been
together this whole times now she's like
so can we listen to it now I'm like let
me take you back I showed her Dr season
one two days ago I showed her the whole
album oh my God it's so good um hearing
the stories about the picture the crack
like oh bro oh I love that [__] so much
um so yeah more stuff this year Marty
we're doing more things out of the
comfort zone do more [__] my back's
getting better yeah it sucks yeah
working it's annoying but all the times
I'm thinking laying on my back
going I can't move what do I give just a
move now I'm like yeah I can't take that
[__] for granted D I got to get up and
fix this so I don't ever lay in there
again because that [__] is not fun and
by the time I'm 50 they're going to have
some thing that fixes your spine I
[__] guarantee it they're going to
have a thing that you put right here
they press the button your spine goes MH
it's going to happen all the disc go
back I I I promise dude Advan technology
the back's going to be good I'm not
worried I need to fix it now I can't
make it to 40 like this my back hurts
too much I can't even
live
so I feel that yeah I feel like by the
time you hit 40 you want to have any
like angering issues overall like I want
to be where I'm at and I want to be like
[__] good at 40 yeah dude I mean it's
it's a while away still it's just years
go quick years go quick we got [__] we
got 10 Christmases this decade think
about it that way you only got 10 in
this decade and if you fail it three
decades imagine saying oh you're not
going to pop do cool [__] for four more
years like then you wouldn't waste a day
and that's how I feel right now like
every day for a fat fat dude every day
that you're like I ate good today I
didn't do nothing bad today and I worked
out it's a [__] win today then every
day you're like no I can't [__] up
because then I'm gonna lose that whole
day I'm about streaks I game of
everything in my head like no I haven't
even meat this H it sounds weird I don't
think I can be vegan anymore mhm I'm not
gonna eat meat anymore I've been looking
at so many studies and so many things
exactly what the [__] is happening to me
in my stomach and my teeth my teeth are
chipping they're not white like they
used to be there's there's some
grayness and I look at it's the number
one thing when people go vegans their
teeth start to deteriorate are you
[__]
me I just stopped drinking milk cuz I
thought it was nasty when I read about
it I don't eat meat because that shit's
sad but I think I I started taking some
whey protein or something soz I'm taking
plant-based protein right now like I
something I started eating honey again
that's one thing like a vegan if you're
a vegan like you're do the honey it's
gross it's bee throw up I get it but
it's really good for you and there's
something I need I need it I'm going to
take that I'm not killing any animals I
don't feel bad I'm not eating a punk of
meat that's fine I can't do me I'm not
going to be able to do that but maybe
maybe I'll take a capsule that
has you know something in it from of
this and it's not you know what I'm
saying where it's not 100% cuz I don't
know what it is guys I
feel I've put on 80 pounds since I went
vegan is that the dumbest [__] you've
ever heard in your life my M got super
unhealthy when she went
vegan I like animals man maybe I'm just
a vegetarian I don't care about cheese
though I don't want to drink milk but
maybe I can take some powders maybe I
can take a supplement that has dairy in
it but happens to help me out like you
cuz at this point dude I feel like I
feel sick inside all the time dude and I
then again I've been eating processed
[__] for a long time vegan but it's
bull I cut that all out I'm not doing
any of that so I'm GNA give it like a
month see how I feel I eat this [__]
out salad at this salad no more juices
all water waking up in the morning I'm
doing all my teas I'm doing all my [__]
taking all my stuff all my protein
Powers ayum this husk all that stuff I
am trying to be that [__] tick tocker
that wakes up in the mornings I wake up
and make my teas like [__] you set that
camera up don't be so dramatic you set
the camera ran back and then did it
that's how I feel right now but like I
just want your routine [__] I'm not
folding my sheet like that I'm I'm not
making my bed that nice I'm sorry just
imagine what mine would be like it's
[__]
ridiculous coffee
and outside is dark the
dark yo every time Marty Ed the phone
he's like this the phone's down here and
he's like That
wos Dying cuz he's ripping a bar with
just lighter fluid not not ripping it
doing this tap it tap yeah I got form I
got when I can find the hump I get it
going that's wild but that's what I know
Marty's outside with one knee up
slightly
down like he's tweaking just trying to
get that bowl off runs
out no my dad like that's what he
doesn't want to have like I got cameras
and [__] now I got Tech going yeah yeah
oh there you go whole house is got
[__] cameraed up I don't but I built
a little structure and [__] with the
bikes and the tarp you blow the smoke
right under the tarp so it [__]
doesn't go everywhere yeah out of
consideration for the neighborhood and
[__] what's that smell I don't know it
smells strong wow it smells like it's
leaking slow leak slow leak no no
actually just smells like
weed slowly leaking out of this like
something dude
you know what I blow smoke in my shirt
at restaurants and sit there and it just
comes out and it looks so funny but no
one's going to say anything cuz you're
not going to go are you on fire no
you're not you're going to take a steam
I try to do that at the [__] soccer
games and [__] it's a bad Lu socer walk
off and come back yeah Marty that's what
I'm saying while I'm doing that I'm kind
of like I'm doing a little quick little
lap around I do that [__] oh that's fine
that's fine dude just full
typing
[__] go good job [__] kill
go Marty's a terrible Dad we find out
Mar's the worst dad
ever yeah I me she Vapes yeah she's
blinking she said Blinky she calls a
blinkies yay blinkers
blinkies we're kidding we're not giving
his child pens kids are [__] clueless
my kids are [__]
clueless they're not they're comedy
right oh man right before I got the F
we'll end it with this forgot it just
sums up Marty's life we're talking about
the most wild [__] his headphones up
he's talking to
me the standing desk and I'm your camera
I'm like yo what's up blah blah blah
yeah [__] out here blah
blah I need toilet paper dad that's all
I hear I need toilet paper 8 minutes
later as Marty's talking Dad I'm like
Marty
have she needed to paper 10 minutes ago
F damn kids always with their [__]
damn kids with their
shits yo so that pretty much sums it up
yo you see Benny's new album yeah these
[__] the hard hold on she's
taking a [__] hold on I'll be
right sums it up dude
B B I need six soccer games today dad
[__] that's really look how look at this
this is real life for this guy every day
trying to explain [__] to the other
parents and [__] yo season 8 is going to
be a whole different ball game when his
kids are like two out of the house and
Em's going to be about 12 to 13 April's
back's fixed she's going to be taking
her everywhere Marty's going to be
sitting
here karate chop of the table here an
hour early we're going to have 90 Vlogs
going it's going to be sick you're going
to walk in I'm just doing push-ups and
[__] in here the Wall come
on upside
down for real yeah cabill buddies that's
where we're going to end it all right I
want to do push-ups on this wall by the
end of the year you know what's crazy is
like it makes me sad but I used to be so
strong and in shape and don't think
about
like what happened to you you piece of
[__] oh yeah you started trapping okay I
got you it's that Reaper is that Reaper
that Reaper will get you y could you
imagine the worst thing ever look at the
ref for at
four get all big and she like
a let it get you man but it's okay you
know what's going to be crazy is when
I'm just like one day like soon I'm just
like damn this fo's buff now like I know
right weird so [__] weird went from
trapped out to trapped out sh trapped
out damn Marty's just a word Smith went
from trapped out to trapped out that's
the series name from trapped out to trap
from tra TOA
trap Mario and the intro is just a
shirtless back mhm tra and then the
tattooos more drugs and then weights on
one side yeah like Hell's Kitchen the
two knives at the end that's
ours it's always like some spilled wine
on Hell's Kitchen ours just like
sweat all buff and The Rock's my
friend yo these are real things you
speaking in the universe you know that
right me and Paul R are get high this
year I don't know if you guys know that
Paul rud's going to sit right there
Ant-Man ant-man's going to be here this
year different building ant-man's coming
this year speak these things into the
universe ant-man's coming this year I'm
so excited just made me sad thinking
about when I was supposed to film The
Rock oh then you got sick I didn't even
get sick you tested sick remember that
[__] yeah I remember it's okay Midnight
it was only a one person shoot and it
was supposed to be Marty in The Rock was
it
we might have had Dwayne Johnson on the
show if Marty didn't test
sick that's okay it's all right we're
put in the universe all right that's all
do some skull crushes with Arnold we do
a lot of things wait skull crusher did I
just do the wrong [__]
workout no I think it's skull crusher
yeah anyway I don't know stuff I want to
get really sick with like body weight
workouts I'd love to be able to work out
having without having to go to the gym
andat be as buff as that Asian man that
puts the towel in his mouth on Tik Tok
and list weights with his neck and it
does the biome biometric stuff but he's
ried see that Asian guy old man that's
where I'm trying all old dudes are
shredded just on the monkey bars that's
really all you need yeah if you're
ethnic of any kind any ethnicity just do
pull-ups you're going to be shredded
like absolutely SH Monster like the way
Little Chihuahua are buffed sometimes
and they're just like oh you can see
your heart beating like yeah but I'm 90
I'm like damn
[__] no [__] you beat my ass never
mind you're not that old yeah that's how
I feel like you're I can see your heart
beating you're like ET all these old men
have ET chests with some PEC on top and
you can see straight into their soul and
if I want I can go and grab that spine
like Kano from from [__] mortal comat
we got to get out of here oh my God what
the [__]
happening but one of my favorite things
I ever thought of uh was was me when we
talk about the burner episode I think
one of my favorite descriptions was he's
like you want to do drugs again I'm like
if I could do drugs I would let Jafar
put me in that [__] sand time piece
and just die in there did you see the
picture I found of her no I saw IM me
just like this get out of here yeah it's
just me with a bucket get out of here
more oh man if drugs weren't bad for you
are you [__] me you guys seen the
weed blow gun I just just throw [__]
Coke in that [__] and just put it right
here turn this turn it on if it didn't
kill you remember how youed to put sugar
on [__] cornflakes as a kid
[Laughter]
uh no more protein powders there should
be no more nothing I don't need sodas
nothing I would just Frosted Flakes
sugar coat everything I do and just get
the [__] out of here sorry this is why
we get in trouble so much I'm over here
saying the that's why we got age
restricted we're about filling up myash
with Coke so much the Japanese dirt
Garden burner episode got age strict to
quick but you know it was worth it
during the premiere which is rare during
the process of a showing it they were
like
whoa I'm not even done with this thing
and it's already too much think about it
it wasn't over there like no just this
is already enough for real it's so
frustrating and people are like I had to
create an account to watch this sh I
know
everybody create a Gmail account okay
off top over here yeah appreciate it but
yeah guys we're in G I thought we're
were going to get out of here at 130 but
you know we ran into a little bit it's
cool guys thank you for being here
accountabil buddies Cat Williams the
truth bunch of stuff hire
Mexicans hire the good ones hire the
ones that speak a couple words in
English cuz not even that hire the dudes
that have paint already on their pants
because that means they've done this
before a lot of these fools jerks out
here wearing like Pumas and like skinny
jeans I ain't hiring nobody with skinny
you know how many people we have hired
through the movie company outside of
Home Depot when we were short-handed in
Oregon a
lot I'm talking triple digits and we
never got the guy with skinny jeans and
pumas you know why he doesn't know what
he's doing he's just there going
you need like a video game player some
like some [__] you what do you need but
no boy I need you to lift
couches I don't know dog my shit's
pretty tight I don't know if I can bend
like that they don't talk like Mexican
FS don't talk like that but that's what
I'm saying they're thinking it I don't
know
dog
um I don't know where we went with that
we get in trouble oh
yeah stand up Mexicans funny only I can
say it it's so crazy it's so crazy what
imagine if I just came out lighter I
would just be [__] oh [__] maybe I be
a movie
star like oh hey hey you say some
terrible [__] um all right well here we
go let's get out of here we've been here
for an hour and a half almost two hours
thank you guys for being here this is
literally the catch a catchup episode
saying how are you start off the new
year and most important please leave
with this this accountability thing
leave it in the comments what is
something you're trying to get done this
year drop it in the doesn't have to be a
nine paragraph thing drop this what I'm
trying to get done January let's go
update me in February I'll put every
single thing yo I lost [__] 19 pounds
this month hell yeah I'm this is it
you're never going to see me this fat
again it's over I can't do it anymore my
back's not going to work my back is not
going to work it's crazy but it's real
that's that that's how they put it but
you're going to be a wheelchair are you
getting my back it's not because I'm too
fat it's just I can't do [__] because
I'm my back hurts but I'm fat because I
don't move it's like yo this drug will
heal you but you're also TR fatally
allergic to this
drug so what so what should I do like
[__] risk it bro let's go for it if
you're dying hit it again like a [__]
all right I'll have two bumps on one in
each hand in case I die I'll hit the
other one that's pretty much how it is
but we're going to get through it of
course it's our luck get
monetized no your back's good no he fat
now it all it's all relative guys get it
done um just if there's something out
there you need to accomplish you can
accomplish it with us it doesn't have to
be podcasting or weed or business it
might be I need to go out and start
talking to people more yo yesterday I
talked to three people in public Marty
and I updated you when we talked to
people in public you're not alone here
man you're not alone Marty just said it
today I got to just talk to people yeah
you do they're nice our fans are nice
man if you're if you know know what I'm
saying I'm not going to beat it into the
ground thank you guys for being here
thank you for being a part of the show
we are still looking to move so when we
do we're going to have a new set we'll
update you guys on that we're excited
burner episode just came out Jake
Johnson episode just came out Brad
Williams Ken Flores and soon come on
Mario Lopez all right let's get this one
out let's get this one knocked out I
don't think ludicrous coming back
anytime soon after the Things We Said
Today you know but then again
ludicrous would anybody even know who
ludicrous is at this point or they okay
all right
because the Fast and Furious 15 okay
yeah Fast and Furious I didn't know if
people still cared about that if that
was man he's ludicrous bro he came in on
strings at the the Falcons game on man
oh yeah that is right that was sick he's
ludicrous man that's why makes me sad
like I like ludic creep what did you say
about M I don't know about you don't you
write a rap to talk to about
Williams you need to go you need to go
bang me along in public make it known
and get
it the sex day every single time one of
our favorite people [__] up just you
need to have sex with me along in like a
public thing and let us let everybody
know like yeah that was
me I'm sorry if I made fun of M Trey
like you know what you're forgiven
You're All Is Forgiven NE are we good
here NE we good and she she's going to
go like
this yes dog since she's are you high Y
oh Mar that's what we're friends I was
going to say you look high I was just
about to say
it oh really
yeah look high can we get out of here
guys thank you for being here oh yes
thank you guys so much for being here
this is Mario O'Neal thank you
guys I was like oh he's i g say nothing
hey thanks guys he said the softest the
softest Michael Jackson thanks guys
that's my radio host that's my like hi
guys Quiet Storm voice it's a quiet
storm your Bob Ras it's 55 de coming out
just be be a little careful I saw a
tweaker here on the high five yep guys
yeah in my course I'm doing full bar
Ross the whole time so get ready for
that let's draw a little tree up here I
watched the last episode of Bob uh the
last sign out of Bob Ross's show
yesterday which very weird I saw it on
Twitter oh sad let's get out of here
guys this is Marty O'Neal there you
[Music]
go
for everyone out there that was Marty
making that noise okay if you're not
watching oh what are we doing if you're
in the car please be safe please drive
carefully well I don't know why we
haven't said that in the past couple
months but be safe if you're in the car
be safe if you're at work careful on
your phone get it Ear Pod be safe if
you're at school do your homework too
because you bro education sucks but
shout out to everybody in school that
Watching Ted Talk too by the way yeah
shout out to you for doing uh the
article on the Ted talk your whole
senior project on our Ted Talk which was
awesome thank you very much they also
showed uh one of my stories uh as a as a
senior closing thing about a business
thing one of my Adventures Channel nice
yeah so CL toy I love that yeah so guys
thank you so much thank you for being
here accountabil buddies accountable be
there help us out help yourself out
whatever it is no matter how big or
small we're here we're here this a whole
Community let's uh stay more connected
let's talk this is Marty O'Neal go
follow Mar already made it on Instagram
Twitter uh Tik Tok YouTube uh my
Instagram dopas Yola sther Snapchat oh
no I have a Snapchat it's Yola is dope
the only one there's a lot of fakes Yola
is dope The Only Name I have out there
Yola is dope and then my Twitter's the
same thing dope as Yola my Tik Tok I'm
logged out so you know damn we'll get it
back right now I didn't get flagged I
got a new phone and and it said my old
number's hooked up so I have to find the
person with my old number convince them
to meet me can't there has to be there's
no other way I even talked to my my
connect on the online social guy he's
like oh man bro you might be out that's
it no no
dude cuz they can't send you the
verification code so I have to text a
person and call them like hopefully
they're cool or if they're not like bro
I'll give you like 200 bucks you want to
meet me at the [__] 7-Eleven or
something no I'm not going to rob you
don't rob me
though you never know or they get there
go I watch your [__] like hell yeah oh I
need a million for this
[__] Mary maybe I'll have somebody else
go yeah I didn't even think have OG show
up not knowing what the [__] going on
yeah
oh that's no that sucks yeah I hope our
fan wouldn't try to extort this extort
this I said like toras and [__] extort
us yo it's time to get out we got to go
extort this
that's the fattest Mexican [__] I've
ever
SE we talking about
extortion okay all right you done we
good all right we're out of here guys
thank you so much leave a like
notification all that [__] thank you
guys so much for being here this has
been the dope as usual podcast until
next time have a dope ass
dayoo head F head phoneless threw a
little Accent on that there the
[__] you
[Music]
perfect